good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday oh
yeah
i didn't even realize it's so beautiful
it's wednesday it's hump day
which means that we're about to get over
the hump and i couldn't be more looking
forward
to getting over to the hump and you're
excited to hump someone you love aren't
you oh yeah it's hump day
even though doo doo doo again 702 said
still not supporting you [ __ ]
and that is what it is he's on strike
he's at home with his father resting
peacefully i love that for him i really
do and you know he's so distracting with
his cuteness and it makes us look like
so busted
and so unprofessional like so i i can
understand that he's done i actually
considered bringing brew
and i think brew is almost ready to
start coming to the show
in an informal capacity he's only been
here twice i don't think he'll
it'll be years before he reaches due's
level of calmness and professionalism
but i think he could i think if he were
to come you would see a whole new brew
because he's really matured in the last
few months and
actually in two weeks he is turning one
that's tough i'm excited i really am
because
every stage of brew's growth has just
been
so beautiful to watch yeah well i
actually haven't seen brew in quite
a while so i don't really i can't speak
on his behavioral status
um i just do remember those days like i
was like you know i could bring theo and
like you'll regret it the second you got
here
yeah no but that's how i felt the last
times because he was so young he was a
puppy but in two weeks he's no longer a
puppy
and i don't know i just i have faith in
brew i really i really do
it's inspiring how much you believe in
him honestly i'm so excited for you to
meet
this man i can't wait to meet this man
cause the last man i met pete in my
house
well he was a little boy twice he was a
little boy he hasn't
had an accident in a very long time and
he went away he didn't have an accident
like
he's been really good and he's been
trying to prove to me like i'm ready to
get to work put me on the show i want to
get involved
well i want to put kibble on the table
i'm like we are just a kid
there is a moment like when a dog
stops being a puppy and like it's like
um there's like a visible
difference in their behavior and it
sounds like you've reached up pinnacle
no he still has puppy tendencies and
like
in the afternoon but starting at six
o'clock on like he
is a mature man he's drinking wine
oh yes reading the newspaper he loves
the cabernet sauvignon after dinner
well speaking of cabaret do you say
cabaret cabernet
well speaking of cabaret i watched the
real housewives of new york this morning
i forgot to watch the last night i was
so
engrossed engrossed in the olympic
village and so much happened in the
olympics
and i didn't even feel bad but then i
woke up i was like oh crap i forgot and
so i'm excited to recap that with you
because we haven't recapped housewives
in like two weeks
yeah we will recap it i mean it's so
hard to care with
everything going on on the television so
hard to care about such a subpar show
when literally the most premium historic
content is being
broadcasted and like what i'm going to
choose to watch real housewives of new
york
no no but but we did what we needed to
do and we'll recap
even though i've already forgotten what
happened hopefully you can remember i
mean it's so fresh in my mind i
literally watched it i swear to god 20
minutes ago i finished it so
i'm uh i'm a well of knowledge that's
perfect
and we have a lot of olympics coverage
it'll be um part of our first story
because there's so much to discuss so
we'll get your thoughts on
everything olympics that you consumed
and other than that i'm
starting to catch up on love island and
i know what i'm about to say is like
so last week's news yeah but go but i
just need to get it off my chest
jeremy did not say that he and amy were
just friends
he did not say that he said we're best
friends and there is a big difference
because in a relationship you hope to be
best friends with your partner not just
friends yeah that was like stupid drama
so i do think that i don't think florida
lied i think she just misheard and
neither of them were lying
but then it's also weird that they won't
call each other liars because they're
like into each other
yeah i actually like was surprised that
there was rockiness between amy and
jeremy because they're such a good
looking couple like
what do they have to fight about i don't
know they could just look in the mirror
all day and just be sober and smile
yeah so i i agree with that that was
like a really dumb there was at some
point last week like a lull
before casa moore it was just like the
same people like trying different things
with the same people
so it definitely needed the refresh of
casa more even though like i hate that i
have to watch new girls
um but you're currently in like the
stage where it's like they're definitely
getting stockholm syndrome like
same people same thing every day same
same same yeah so that's just
where i'm at i really want jeremy to
find love because like i
just want him to stay on the but he's
like really not into anyone that's on
him like i
hate him he doesn't put forth any effort
like after him and amy got to a better
place like
he literally reached out his hand and
like she had to get up and give him a
hug and they weren't even looking at
each other
he's so weirdly like not affectionate
not visibly into anyone he went from
being like one of my favorites
and when things didn't work out with him
and trina i was like that's too bad but
you know what
you're not gonna be into everyone like i
have to accept that then like he's being
all weird with amy he just has like the
weirdest relationships
and i think there's something like weird
with him i think he's like a weird guy i
think he's a weird guy too
and it's just disappointing because we
were rooting for you we were all rooting
for we were
all [ __ ] rooting for jeremy and now
i'm so like blase about him i don't even
like care
yeah so i need to continue catching up
but that was just like something that
was really
bothering me and i wanted to like see
what if people online like were agreeing
but then i would have seen like a
million other
spoilers no no being behind on love
island is so dangerous like i was
one episode behind what
one on tick tock the love island tick
tock posted a spoiler like it wasn't a
spoiler because
it aired it aired but like my god give
us a day like you're on
five days a week like not everyone is
gonna be keeping up to the you know
to the minute yeah i understand it
wasn't like a huge spoiler
um but i was like i was so mad at myself
you know yeah
damn okay well i'm gonna continue with
that there's no beverly hills on tonight
is that what you had said
yeah i read that somewhere and i have no
idea why but again like i'm constantly
reading things that are lying to me so
much like the podcast reviews that we
read all the time we don't know anything
about anything so it might be on
we know some stuff okay julian i saw
meme that it wasn't on this me too
that's
when i say i read i saw a meme okay cool
cool cool christian gray snow
yep okay so that's our source and if you
have an issue with what we read then
check the bibliography okay check the
bibliography thank you
and then check yourself um no but
that'll give us time to catch up on
olympics love island etc
and i finished my book last night ship
of dreams nothing really new to report i
i just feel like you don't really care
about like the titanic factoids that i
was
that i would want to know you know i
didn't even bring my kindle with my
highlights like i didn't even oh
i didn't mean to discourage you and
maybe if i get like
there's like some commotion from was
there any commotion when you initially
announced your journey into the titanic
um well but i wasn't really it wasn't
overwhelming i just
maybe i didn't
things happen but other than that for me
i feel prepared to get into what we need
to get into
i actually felt like a really exciting
day ahead of me do you know if i told
you actually i don't know if i should
spoil it like it's not my it's not my
news to share
oh oh yeah it's not yours it's not my
news okay you'll see it on my instagram
later i'm just really excited to be a
part of someone's special day
i'm excited for you and you'll tell us
all about it tomorrow yeah yeah yeah
yeah
quick okay i'm so glad i didn't spoil it
i don't know if that was like
appropriate or not yeah
i i couldn't it could go either way but
air on the side of caution for sure for
sure for sure
first we're just like so secretive oh my
gosh like
secret personal protection so many
secrets
so many jackhammers um should we dive in
i think we should dive in to the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
because i feel as though you need to
know them i really do okay
today's episode is brought to you by
framebridge here's how it works so you
can be
stylin while in livin it up in the city
framebridge makes it easy and more
affordable than ever to frame your
favorite things without ever leaving the
house
add a gallery wall to your home office
or send the perfect gift from art prints
and diplomas to photos sitting on your
phone
you can frame bridge just about anything
you can frame all the fun memories you
collect this summer from photos ticket
stubs coasters and more
here's how it works go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo or
they'll send you packaging
to safely mail in your physical pieces
preview the item online in dozens of
different frame styles gallery wall
layouts you'll choose your favorite
or you can get free recommendations from
their talented designers the experts at
frame bridge will custom frame your item
and deliver you finished
your finished piece directly to your
door instead of hundreds you'd pay at a
framing store their prices start at 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners can get 15 off their first
order at frame bridge when they use code
toast they also are opening up a couple
um in-person stores in new york dc
atlanta and philly
boston and chicago are coming soon the
framing industry is so archaic
so outdated and framebridge is just like
bringing the framing industry
into the 21st century it's so affordable
and it's really stunning and good
quality
get started today frame your photos or
send someone the perfect gift
go to framebridge.com and use the promo
code toast to save an additional 15
off your first order that's
framebridge.com promo code
toast framebridge.com promo code toast
as you guys know i have a stunning photo
framed of myself in my room from framage
but you know what that is a great gift
if like you were to take
a really great photo of someone and then
you were to send it to them that's a
really good gift
you know what my favorite thing to do is
like when i'm staying at someone's house
like
when i went to brian's um i noticed he
had lots of photos of his friends and
none of me
so i went to frame ridge and framed a
couple photos of us and then i brought
it as a housewarming gift
that makes me look like a nice guest and
then i finally get a place in his home
it's mutually beneficial yeah it was
really like offensive
yeah but you you righted that wrong
that's my favorite thing to do i did to
my friend anna too like i got her these
stunning photos of us like from high
school middle school all grown up and
i'm like for you but like it's for me
because i went to her house and it was
not a [ __ ] picture of me
yeah no i think that works really out
for everyone if someone brought me
pictures i don't care what they look
like
that's fun that there's pictures i know
i love um having pictures in my home for
a while i feel like we spoke about this
i had like no pictures in my house of
like my family or like me i
i now have some pictures in my house
zach has made sure of it but
it was never a priority for me yeah like
if you walked into my home it's like a
mausoleum like you don't know who lives
here
yeah there's a ghost haunting the halls
yeah also with frameworks it does make
it so easy like i really don't want to
have to go to the store print out my
photos and then like buy it and frame
that
that matches well we're not doing that
that's why so i guess with the advent of
frame bridge was when i got my [ __ ]
together yeah
you know totally okay first story big
olympics news simone biles withdraws
from olympic individual all-around
gymnastics competition
after team opt-out okay this is the
second half of the story that we
reported on yesterday which
when we reported it i was still a little
confused but then watching it last night
like i understand yeah
and it's actually really confusing to
understand the olympics because
we're getting second-hand information
and we're not watching until about 12
hours later
what had happened with simone happened
yesterday at 6 45 a.m so we're reading
all these reports from like e-news
nobody knows what the hell they're
talking about and then at 8 p.m it was
on and you got to see exactly what
happened exactly
clearly unwell yeah so simone will also
not participate in the women's
gymnastics individual all-around this
week usa gymnastics announced in a
statement on wednesday
the announcement came after she
unexpectedly bowed out of the women's
gymnastics team final on tuesday night
at the tokyo olympics
quote after further medical evaluation
simone biles has withdrawn from the
final individual all-around competition
at the tokyo olympics
in order to focus on her mental health
simone will continue to be evaluated
daily to determine whether or not to
participate in next week's individual
event finals
okay so there's still i'm holding out
hope that confused me because i thought
it's like we do the team and then we do
the
individuals i guess there's multiple
individuals and so simone doesn't
compete does that mean an alternate gets
to compete jade carrie who had the
number
she's great she but she had the ninth
highest score in the qualifications will
participate in her place in the
all-around
she's at the olympics because she
qualified in an individual spot yes but
there are but there are also like a
bunch of other alternates and
michaela skinner didn't make it so like
she technically could no yeah but she
didn't qualify at the olympics
so it's going to be jade and i mean
that's a great opportunity for her yes i
feel like an alternate like
never gets yeah never gets to play
because like who would
ever not compete but simone is making a
historic decision for herself
she is to not move forward yeah so
as we saw last night she did her vault
and it did not go as planned for her she
got her lowest vault olympic score ever
and you know nastia liu can actually
explained it really well what had
happened
because she said when you like fly
through the air with the greatest of
ease like
you need to have spatial awareness you
need to understand where you are
in your routine where you are in regards
to the floor and for the most part like
if you're a professional like simone you
know exactly what's happening where you
are
but you can get like a case of like the
dizzies where you kind of get
disoriented and you don't realize like
where you are so simone in her head was
ready to do it was supposed to be two
and a half twists
she ended up doing one and a half
because she was about to go into the
second one but she was at the floor she
didn't realize
the floor was there she thought she had
more space yeah so it's called the
dizzies according to nausea
yes and so after that she took herself
out of the competition
citing mental health um concerns and she
had also said that during the warm-ups
she just
wasn't like feeling herself she wasn't
feeling like herself
and uh then she warmed up again five
hours later and just she felt like off
the whole day and then after that vault
she decided to not go forward i have to
say i also watched the
qualifiers like to make team usa and she
seemed off as well and i was like maybe
she's just like not giving it her all
because like
she doesn't want to like exert too much
effort like save it for the olympics but
she fell off the beam in the qualifier
she was off in the
qualifications too but i just kind of
wrote that off as like
preserving her energy but now looking at
the whole picture seeing kind of every
step of the way it's very clear that she
hasn't been
in a right state of mind for more than
just yesterday you know
right i think it's been a while and i
think a lot of people forget that like
simone everyone had a hard year
obviously
but simone also was going through the
entire larry nassar right
uh situation she was vocal about being
one of his abusers
and no being sorry a victim of his abuse
and she did an interview um with her mom
about like the process of coming to
terms with that and like sharing that
she was one of the girls um so it's just
a lot and i
and i hear everyone being like she can't
like just like stop
like yeah oh and by the way we had
discussed yesterday how michael phelps
was probably going
to reach out to her and michael phelps
he's you know the swimming correspondent
he did okay good also i read somewhere
that he said that
the extra year the covet year was
was bad for the veterans but good for
the younger they're a year older right
but for
younger um newer athletes like they had
an extra year to perfect their craft
they're better this year than they were
last year grace mccollum said like if i
didn't have this year i probably
wouldn't have made the olympics
right so i'm sure like all of these
factors go into you know simone's
decision and also
i think snitch had sent me that one of
the reasons simone decided to come back
to the olympics was because she is the
last
teammate who is a survivor of dr larry
nassar's abuse and she doesn't and she
wants to keep the pressure on usa
gymnastics to like be held accountable
and it's just that makes me so sad that
like that she still doesn't feel like
and
because i don't really feel like there's
been any repercussions without the
gymnastics community aside from you know
the larry himself but so many people
were touching old and like new and i'm
sure these girls went to people high up
in the organization and was just like
swept under the rug and so she feels
that burden of responsibility to make
sure that
there's justice for the girls but why
can't there just be justice for the girl
100 i saw that interview it's the same
interview she was you should watch it
actually her and her mom
she said like one of the big reasons i'm
here is because like you can't ignore me
and if i'm still talking about larry
nassar and usa gymnastics
involvement in the situation like we we
can't sweep it onto the rug anymore
so it's an incredibly like brave thing
to do i think her
interest right now is like protecting
future gymnasts but like honestly [ __ ]
usa gymnastics
seriously see i feel so torn because
like i want like
i really care about the girls and like i
want them all to like win gold and i
know it's so important to them
but like i kind of want usa gymnastics
to lose like [ __ ] you like you this is
what happens when you don't protect the
girls
yeah but like i want the girls to win
their medals you know i'm feeling torn i
just we need some
action we need some firings over at usa
gymnastics like anyone who was involved
in this
um horrible situation like must go
no i agree and like i i'm firing for
sure but like i'm ready for some people
to go to jail
oh that's that too but it's like brother
i wonder if simone is like competing and
for usa gymnastics when there are people
there who maybe some of the girls went
to to confide in
who didn't have their back yeah and you
know what's really interesting i think
that like we'll see
a whole new side of simone when she's
officially done with the olympics
because if you're competing on behalf of
usa gymnastics
you have to behave a certain way because
you're going into gymnastics you're
going to the olympics with them but when
she's officially out of like usa
gymnastics rule like she's just like a
celebrity
i think her voice is going to be like
even 10 times more powerful i think
she's going to speak on things
like in a much more direct and real way
but right now she's still technically a
part of the organization
yeah that is true so then last night
jordan child stepped in first moan i
thought she did an amazing job i felt
really sad
for her because i think she like from
what i could see they were like
they had a strong chance after someone
was out they did beam and they did bars
and they had a real chance
and then jordan did her floor routine
and she fell really hard and the
announcers were like there's no way they
can win now
but like it's important for everyone to
remember like jordan did a balance
routine
and a bounce beam routine and a bars
routine that she was not supposed to do
i don't even know if she had
rehearsed it like she was filling in for
someone i'm sure she was [ __ ] tired
yeah no she did her absolute best which
is great which was
great i thought that it was it was a
great performance i thought
suny lee just put the whole country on
her back suny [ __ ]
oh my god every every trick everything
everything which
was fantastic and you know what i feel
like i really know the girls now and
and i think a major shout out needs to
go to grace mccollum because she
she's not the best but she's so steady
and she's all in
so solid and so good and i feel like she
gets like forgotten about because she's
not like simone and like suny
is like the shiny new but like grace
mccollum is a true
reliable team member yeah she just
always she never does like the best most
craziest she always does really really
good
that's great that's that's you always
need like a steady
yeah but you see sunny is she was
incredible oh my god
spectacular but you know who else was
spectacular
the russians oh my god the most gorgeous
that last floor routine oh and when she
knew that she nailed it
so russia is competing as the roc
the russian olympic committee because
they were disqualified for doing
like foreign olympics yes
and i just feel like let's test the
girls
i'm kidding i just was so bummed
obviously a silver medal is amazing but
like we crushed gymnastics like
no but they deserved it like 100 their
performances i mean there was a lot of
like beams slip up
beam was turned like everyone was just
like sliding off the beam
yes yeah and when they would do the
replay and you see
you see the girls faces when they
realize that they're they have to jump
no yeah that they're not about to stay
on this beam like
it's so upsetting no i know and like the
beam
like really keeps me up at night like
it's so dangerous like
there's no need for people to be like
doing flips on a beam
i just wonder if any of those any of the
gymnasts in the
in tokyo right now if beam is their
favorite no way or just every
i just feel like everyone's like i can't
wait to get beam over with
there's no way that anyone like craves
the beam i
100 yeah what's your favorite
so stressful floor for me and i just
every time i see a floor
i'm just like tbt ally raisman haven't
aguila
of course i literally brought it up to
bed last night i made him watch the
video i almost pulled up the video
because i just that was such an amazing
moment i said to ben i'm like have you
seen the ally raisman one he's like yeah
and he just said that just shut me up
i'm like oh really what song did she
dance to he's like you know like the
beats and i'm like
yeah no um but also justice for vault
a stunning activity yeah
it is pretty stunning and it's over
quickly you know so it's like you're not
biting your nails no the beam like it
kills me like and we used to do i mean
everyone did gymnastics growing up but
like the beam was like traumatizing it's
so [ __ ] dangerous my kids are not
getting on the beam no
i i agree i mean obviously it's a sign
of
immense talent core balance even like
those okay the wolf turns do you know
what those are yeah when you're like
it's almost like break dancing
yes yes yes they do it on beam and on
floor and it's literally like the
hardest thing ever i need gymnastics to
get rid
i see those especially on the beam and
they give me such a pit yeah no that's
not even what gives me a pit it's just
like everything else
everything and i love how like the
dismount on a beam is like the easy part
right because it's like it's physically
it looks like the hardest but there's
really not much balance required because
you just like
just do your thing but they're also
probably so excited that it's over yeah
no like
they're always on the announcers are
always being like just the dispatch now
it's like oh only the hardest part
yeah so i also i love bars but it's just
gonna say
also there was a russian um gymnast i
think she was the youngest one i think
she was 16 who did
a floor routine that was so cute do you
see with her dancing yes yes yes and she
was having so much popping
she was like kick like this is her i was
just like you go girl i know i actually
feel like sometimes the floor routines
are so
like routine like they need that's why
having aguila was so iconic because it's
a song
most people recognize and like she was
really like vibing like sometimes it
just feels very robotic
i agree but then you've seen stick it
and you know that the song can't have
music
but you know there are lyrics yeah
lyrics there are so many orchestral
songs and i think one of the
american girls was actually um tumbling
to the spider-man um oh i'm not familiar
with soundtrack i only knew that because
zach was like spider-man i was like i
guess
yeah so that's a pretty cool way to you
know get some
some personality in there yeah i just i
really need some usa gold like not to
put too much pressure on the girls
but um i think when they compete
individually they really are all like
so good yeah that i just can't wait also
if you're looking for
premium [ __ ] olympic coverage you
have to follow
um leslie jones on tick tock okay
it is only tick tock i don't know if she
posts them on other platforms like tic
tac she's like become obsessed with the
tick tock
it is so pretty no she's watching she's
filming her tv but i feel like
at the last olympics she was there as a
correspondent why does that sound
familiar
she's a huge sports veteran she was
doing olympics coverage
it's very possible yeah but she probably
like didn't make them but her tick tock
is so funny like please enjoy okay um
all day yesterday i was watching
like literally the most obscure there
was so much
equestrian on so boring like it's not
horse racing they're just like
jumping no not even like the horses are
doing like
the doggy like it's so random i don't
really get it it was so boring but i did
watch surfing which was
fascinating and carissa moore from
america won the first olympic medal in
surfing by the way you were right
yesterday
is a brand new sport yeah and um she won
the first women's
medal for that and a really big deal the
us
lost to japan in softball it was like a
really big deal
yeah then i watched diving synchronized
diving oh my god
so hard like the woman who was like
announcing for nbc
like these girls like jumped off they
did the literally the exact same flip at
the exact same time
oh look at that entry oh no that's
that's a deduction
it's like girl shut up like they're
literally so in sync it was crazy
us came in second and these two prodigy
teenagers from china who literally
when one moved the other moves like it
was crazy like looking in a mirror
day one and they totally deserved it
then the swimming
so much trauma because it was a lot of
um like semi-finals
and it's just like metal still yeah show
us
on i watched swimming and then like
katie ledecky came in fifth
oh my god so katie ledecky ran and i
lost i was just feeling like every time
i'm watching
we're not winning maybe i should stop
watching and we'll win some katie
ledecky
and then that's what happened she won
1500 meter she swam a couple days ago
and there was like this
really big younger swimmer from
australia who like really looks up to
katie and
katie lost to her and it was like a big
deal but katie came in second whatever
then katie swam again last night and it
was like all right whatever she had an
off night
she came in fifth yeah and we were like
what's going on then they added a brand
new um
race the 1500 free and basically when
you have to qualify for the olympics and
you just like compete in world
championships
outside of the olympics there's always
the 500
free but it was never in the olympics
but it's like katie ledecky's
thing it's so long it's 30 laps there
and back like so it's like
one two one
two no no so it's like one wait what are
you doing
like there in back is one or there is
one there in back is one
and thirty of those three thirty there
and back yeah they went to a commercial
break in the middle of the race like it
was literally 30 minutes
that's crazy but she won by amaya like
because it's so
her endurance and then her teammate she
was even more excited for her teammate
who swam right behind well not right
behind her because katie was so far
ahead of everyone but came in second
got the silver and we just stand like i
feel like she's having a hard time and i
was
trying to google if she was dating
anyone because i was just like curious
because she's like super famous
and basically like what all the articles
were like she's not interested like she
is focused on her goals goals goals so i
feel like she's taking these losses
you know really hard yeah um so i'm
really glad she got that 1500 millimeter
width yeah that and that's a big win
because that is a millimeter
neither millimeter i could do that is a
show of strength oh my god it was so
long i was like how are these girls not
dying
and then they had to do an interview i'm
like how are they talking i was thinking
i'm like if that was me
they had to pull themselves out of the
pool afterwards i'm like you would
literally
need to like pull me out on a stretcher
i could not get out of the pool because
they you know
there's not a ladder like they just push
themselves out i'm like holy [ __ ] that's
what i was more impressed with right but
it's like after everything they've done
like the push is really it's known it's
not it's nothing for them
so caleb dressle did good um my
boyfriend so it's just been an exciting
such an exciting time i mean yeah and
with this gymnastic stuff it's like
unprecedented everyone's talking about
it
and it's really crazy i look i i really
look forward to seeing what the girls do
i think
they need to regroup like as a team
because i think once watching it like
when simone
left and it was unclear like why she was
leaving if she was okay i think the
girls were just like frazzled
frazzled but then also like jordan had
to go straight to the bars no of course
like it was so unsettling
and she did amazing considering all i
would have been thinking about is like
is simone what's going on with the moon
considering she wasn't supposed to do
that right when was when do you think
the last time she did that routine was i
don't know maybe she'd probably practice
it in the gym but like still
right so i just i think once you know
team usa anything now that simone's head
says she's not doing individuals like
jade carry can get in there they can
reset they can reset and i think
i'm really looking forward to seeing
what they bring yeah um
so olympic coverage constantly coming at
you we should be in tokyo
yet here we are so that's that on that
yeah but maybe you know
if we're doing such a good job this year
like we'll be in paris in
24. or la28
i know i saw that well we could go if we
wanted yeah we could just like show up
nobody in paris nobody supplies over
there like we could just get on the
plane
yeah okay ready for our next story yeah
paris hilton says she can't wait to have
children after denying pregnancy rumors
so yesterday after we wrapped the toast
it came out that paris hilton was
pregnant period you know of course we're
like we missed the breaking news
right we missed the breaking news and
you know all day like other
media outlets were writing it up and
then you know paris took to her podcast
to say no i'm not um she also said that
she does want to become a mom she said i
love being a boss babe i love working
hard i'm running a huge empire so i'm
always focused on my business but one
day when i become a mother i'm not going
to be traveling the way that i used to
it was too much um
paris it's the true meaning of life it
brings you so much joy and so much love
that you can never even have imagined
before i just can't wait for that one
day
though that day is not today she said
she woke up yesterday to about
3 000 texts all my iphones are blowing
up
all five of them everyone's all my
iphones everyone wishing me
congratulations and so happy for me
heard from people i haven't heard from
in years but then she denied it on her
episode of this is paris podcast
so glad i didn't text her she said one
day i can't wait to have a little girl i
want to name her london
one day there will be a mini parrot
there will be mini paris and minnie
carter's but not yet
stay tuned for 2022. well i think this
was really believable because
one in her youtube documentary when she
was like at nikki's house playing with
the kids she talked about how she
definitely wants to have kids
and then she's been open about um how
her and carter are thinking about or
starting the ivf process right
so i actually wasn't surprised by it at
all and they are doing ivf
currently right so but she's not
pregnant yeah
okay so i just feel like speculating
about people's pregnancies is really
weird like
where did this this come from like let's
say it was like a super valid report
like i think people should be able to
announce their pregnancies when they
want i agree with that
like on their social media or and i did
think we were done like with this sort
of thing
yeah like this is so arcade especially
considering it wasn't true
right and if you enjoyed it if you're
gonna like blow up someone's spot make
sure it's true
yeah i mean this kind of reminds me
of one of my biggest like pits
is when i announced on the chose
instagram and i got a really um
really like solid source told me that um
mj from shaw's was pregnant
right and she literally commented on the
post no i'm not and then i took it down
because i was like so pin inducing
and then she announced the next day but
she wanted to make her own announcement
she was 100 right and i was wrong
and that's a learning lesson i learned
such i was i remember i was at the us
open
and i literally had the biggest pit of
my entire life
i will never do that again and we've
gotten a lot of like really
solid pregnancy tips and i've never
posted them like someone gave me a
really good tip katherine mcphee was
pregnant before she was and like
i just didn't post it like it's not my
business no it's not your business
and it's just so personal also sometimes
you have to learn stuff the hard way
because like telling someone you
shouldn't say that about a pregnant
person before they're
you're like okay yeah sure but like you
will you'll never forget that pit
ever and that pit lives with you and
that pit is constantly teaching you and
i'm
so grateful that she's still like is my
friend because like i was so
she had like an exclusive with people
she's like you're blowing up my [ __ ]
spot like stuff
yeah yeah totally i'm really sorry mj
like
if only you know like that's like on the
list of things that like keep me up at
night but i just think when someone
feels that badly about something
it's on the list of things that keeps
them up at night like we have no choice
you may chase a kid
no no like it's like i don't want to add
to you already
like no matter what i say you're going
to feel bad i'm not going gonna add to
that yeah you know and like you know
shams is
like four now maybe we can move past us
no still friends
never okay are you ready for our next
story it's um it's some pretty
crazy bathing habits news that i'm
really looking forward to pcbh
that i'm really looking forward to
getting your thoughts on well it's the
pcbhn brought to you by pg
public goods um all right you guys
public goods is the one stop shop
everything you need for sustainable high
quality everyday essentials
that are made from clean ingredients at
an affordable price they sell everything
from coffee toilet paper shampoo
pet food i happen to love their hand
soap their olive oil
and their surface cleaner it is your new
everything store thoughtfully designed
for the conscious consumer so rather
than buying a bunch of single product
brands public goods members can buy all
of their premium essentials in one
beautiful place with a streamlined
aesthetic they search the globe to find
clean healthy eco-friendly and
innovative products
that are all ethically sourced they
obsessively develop each of their
products be free of unhealthy
ingredients and harmful additives
still common um in drug and grocery
store shelves they are committed to
making their products healthy and safe
for humans
animals and the environment so all their
products that i currently use smell
so good the hand soap is in my guest
bathroom divine this surface cleaner
like
i'm a nubella like i'm so constantly
just like cleaning my services surface
is who bacteria who
the bottles like you can actually leave
them out on your counter i usually don't
like to have like a soap i like to put
it in like a jar you know
but everything they make is like
stunning i think that's like a
cornerstone of their brand like we only
make stunning products
and aesthetically pleasing and all of
our products look nice together whether
it's a kitchen item whether it's a food
item like these things can co-exist
and so like once you become a member you
just get everything from there and then
everything in your house looks like
nobela's house um and we've got a great
deal for our listeners if you want to
get 15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase they are so
confident that you will love their
products and come back again and again
that they are giving you 15 to spend on
your first purchase right now you can
receive your choice of either a free
pack of bamboo straws or reusable food
storage wraps with your order
you literally have nothing to lose just
go to publicgoods.com
toast and use the code toast at checkout
that's p u b l i
c g o o d s dot com forward slash toast
to receive 15
off your first order knowing what's in
your products
and where they come from is important
yes it is
okay next story mila kunis and ashton
kutcher raised eyebrows after revealing
their family's bathing habits
okay i saw this mila kunis and ashton
kutch are making headlines after
chatting about their family's bathing
habits during a recent interview on dax
shepard and monica padman's podcast
armchair expert
the subject came up when dax explained
his ongoing argument with monica that
she should not wash her body with soap
he said you should not be getting rid of
all the natural oil on your skin with a
bar of soap every day
it's insane um i don't know if i agree
with that well mila kunis and ashton
kutcher do
they said i don't want she said i don't
wash my body with soap every day
but i wash piss and tits and holes and
souls
as for her husband he said i wash my
armpits and my crotch
daily and nothing else ever he said i
got a bar of lever 2000 that just
delivers
every time nothing else and then monica
was speaking for all of us what the [ __ ]
is monica it's dax's co-host
oh oh oh was surprised by the revelation
she said i can't believe i'm in the
minority here of washing my whole body
in the shower
with soap she said who taught you not to
wash
and mila said it became it began as a
matter of circumstance she said i didn't
have hot water growing up as a child
so i didn't shower very much anyway then
she said the habit continued when she
became a mom when i had children i also
didn't wash them every day
i wasn't the parent that bathes my
newborns ever
sheppard then noted that he and kristen
bell only bathe their own
then newborn daughters as part of our
nighttime routine we could care less
about their cleanliness he said we
haven't watched them since it's been
like six years
emily kunis said that's how we feel
about our children we're like oof
something smells
well it seemed like the star was joking
kutcher weighed in with this he said
here's the thing
if you can see the dirt on them clean
them otherwise there's no point
okay so i just want to say like and i
feel like i've actually had this
conversation with ben like when we're
drunk like
it is crazy that like you know people
survive for millions of years like
with like taking monthly baths like that
but we
we have evolved like evolution is a
thing and like we now live in a society
where you have to shower every day like
and trust me it's hard i hate showering
but i'm not subscribing to this weird
alternative like hollywood free thinking
way of living like i'm going to shower
and so are my kids and if that makes me
a bad mom then so be it well here's the
thing i do think on a necessity level
like
you don't need to shower every single
day like for cleanliness sake and also
like if you say you were to even do
every other day lift then like then
you're
getting the dirt off and you're clean
but and also it's not really even dirt
like what dirt are you accumulating
but bacteria showering is a mental thing
like it's just part of my routine it's
not like i'm so dirty i need to shower
it's just like time to
shower oh no for me it's like don't want
to start smelling
time to shower oh no like if i missed a
shower one day like it would only just
mess with my head like my body is fine
oh that's so funny i'm the opposite like
i love not showering but like then when
i do the next day i just feel like a
like a layer of stick
you know yeah yeah but i'm sure like uh
like actually physically you
don't need to like use soap every single
day it's probably like not great for you
but i just love it
no and like when it comes to kids i
guess like i can understand like if a
kid doesn't smell like why do you need
to shower like i actually
i can see that but like as grown people
who are have agency over their
you know lives i think we should all be
showering i agree and trust me
this pains me to say i hate showering oh
i love it so much but i
i think newborns they obviously like
what are they doing their feet don't
even hit the floor like
they're not accumulating dirt maybe they
get hot i don't know
so they don't need a shot like a bath
all the time and i don't think they get
bats off they take once a week but i
think
kids need i think kids are probably
because more dirt than adults they're
in paste foraging picking their nose
eating their boogers putting
them in the playground i think these
kids should be showering
i agree i actually think like middle
schoolers are probably the most
disgusting
i think we're talking about like six
seven is that not middle school no
oh i'm in elementary school yeah kids
no like no i think kindergarteners are
uh
cleaner than like a fourth grader yeah i
guess that's true
fourth graders are disgusting you know
from experience no like honestly
don't get me wrong like i definitely
want to have kids but kids are so gross
sometimes like
yeah they they really do even your own
it's like other kids yeah but mine no
yours too
like they're all just like gross and
then they get like this weird ugly stage
you know
like where they're just like weird and
they have like little hair on their lip
i don't know i'm just like nervous
because like yes all kids are beautiful
until they're not you know i don't know
some kids sail right through that at
that stage
very few very few and trust me it's not
going to be me and men's
no but like you'll you'll always know
it's like
i don't know i feel like you're just
really scarred by bran stark and
yes that's exactly because other than
that like i really don't look at kids
and i'm like you're in an ugly state
oh you got to start looking at life that
way it's so much fun
oh no i really don't think about it that
way ever and maybe like the parents
can't see it cause like you're so in
love with your child that like even when
they're in their ugly stage like they're
always beautiful to you
but i'm just very logical and i know
ugly you know
yeah yeah but kayla will never have an
ugly phase in her life
exactly and that's how you're supposed
to feel yeah and that's how you will
feel
yeah like for sure anyways
um i love to shower but you know to each
their own no i just didn't know this was
a thing you know like in hollywood like
we're not using soap
since when did soap become like so
outdated yeah and tits and pits and
holes and souls like that's so crazy
you know like it's crazy that there's
like a song for it and yeah like it's
crazy she came up with a phrase like
a catchphrase to explain like why she
doesn't like shower
yeah that's just not how i was raised we
were so privileged to live in a country
with
so much running water so many options
for soap yeah and i'm not going to take
advantage of that no i am going to take
advantage of that i won't take it for
granted no
me neither i love i love soap i just
love
cleanliness i wonder how they feel about
hand washing
then like do they then they're probably
not the kind of people who wash their
hands
after every time they go to the bathroom
and you know what that makes them super
spreaders
are you ready for our next story it's a
little unnecessary reboot news that
nobody asked for
what now pretty little liars is coming
to hbo max the reboot
cast bailly madison in the lead
i can't sorry
sorry bailey you just said like
like a lamb
[Laughter]
he could are you gonna walk off
[Laughter]
can't wait to watch that on the reshow
repeat
rewatch okay okay okay
hbo max's upcoming drama pretty little
liar's original sin has found its
leading lady
they have cast good witch star bailey
madison in the starring role of
imogen described as a true survivor
according to deadline the revival is a
darker and more twisted version of the
series which aired from 2010
to 2017 and was based on the best of
selling books by sarah shepard
the new show is set to is set in the
present day and features new story arcs
and brand new characters
and potentially the option for the
characters to call the police when
something bad happens
did you afraid that i absolutely let me
get up
like wow no way um okay
no no you guys the show ended
yesterday like why not just continue it
if you're going to bring it back this is
out of hand
no this is out of hand like the show was
a joke when it was on
and it's a joke in the reboot even
though i really low-key like baileyman
isn't sorry but lee madison
oh i like her so much give me two so i
think she's cute whatever but like just
know like stop like
why where is the creative energy write a
new show
no it is so so crazy and it's not a show
that people are begging for like people
people die they're like give us another
episode of friends like they did
something stupid with friends
there's no demand here so why the supply
no and also like
people are still watching the old one
like it's still very much like you know
something that you just watched
on netflix it just ended if you're gonna
bring it back also like you could use
the original cast
also like didn't they have a spin-off on
free form
right yeah with sasha uh-huh yeah
it's just like they're trying to make it
into like this universe you know and
like
no we don't care yeah like you spin off
schmidt offs reboots like different
stories different arcs
alternate endings we really don't care
like we really don't
yeah we really don't i think um this is
a no for me
me as well um and i just don't know who
this is for because i do feel like the
fans of pretty little liars like
want the integrity of the original show
to be kept intact
yeah and also the fans of pretty little
liars are grown up
yeah so it's just it's so crazy but
remember when that show like was so good
for five seconds
no that show was like so crazy and i
made such big stars out of all of them
and it was
it was a great show it was definitely
but there are so many others who do you
think is the most famous out of all four
shay mitchell give me two um there are
so many other
like books and series out there that
could be made into shows like
get on it totally you know totally
like there's good stuff every time i
read a book i'm like there should be a
movie
get to work no by the way i literally
feel that about every book right
but then the movie happens and i'm like
you shouldn't have done that you should
have left well enough alone
yeah okay our fifth and final story is a
little
bit of of sad end of an era news sad end
of an era news
okay thank you now i feel right feel at
peace yeah
pbs children's show arthur will be
ending after 25 seasons
are they still on it looks like
everyone's favorite anthropomorphic
aardvark is finally retiring his iconic
yellow sweater
and fist arthur arthur the longest
running children's cartoon in the u.s
history
is slated to end next year after its
upcoming 25th season
in the winter of 2022 the 25th and final
season of
arthur will debut i'm really not looking
forward to the year of 2022
no you shouldn't no honestly i didn't
even know
you can't lose something you never had
so like i never knew the shoe the show
was still on i thought it was like a
relic i thought it was on for like five
minutes when i was a kid
no totally and also the news was first
dropped during an episode of the
podcast called finding dw
with the writer and editor who
originally developed a program from pbs
oh podcasts making news you look right
you knew there was a you know gw is like
arthur's gal
i only know that because there's a sound
on tick tock that went viral
hey dw that's dw oh cutie uh she's very
familiar
and she's very famous in the meme world
yeah yeah arthur's fist
yeah i mean i guess like it said that
it's ending but again i just found out
that there's 25 seasons so
it's technically good news for me right
what's the tick tock sounds
hey dw hey mom why are you touching my
stuff
i don't know it's like a random take
talk sound
oh arthur's sister and
gal and people say we don't know what
we're talking about
that's cute i'm happy for them so that's
the law
that's writing tv showing like i'm just
cartoon spongebob
spongebob it's still around for sure
i don't know can we get a a season check
on spongebob
yeah started in 1999.
1999 so it hasn't been 25 years so it
hasn't
been it's been like 22. so this one is
so so basically spongebob will probably
eclipse
this record if they go on for three more
things keep going the way that they're
going for spongebob is
so good what's your favorite episode of
spongebob um
actually think spongebob might be over
as well like i think it's not even on
the air anymore but what was your
favorite episode
i don't know the one where sandy like
becomes a pop star is really good but
also the one where
um who was it like squidward had never
had a
krabby patty and then he like became
hooked he was addicted like needed his
fix like eating them
out of the dumpster oh so good that's
really sad i relate to squidward
100 like those annoying [ __ ] sponges
um totally
um so those are the best stories correct
yes i feel as though you need to know
them
i feel as though as well um all right
we've got tv recap for the first time in
a while because the real house is in new
york
unfortunately we're on television last
night um and the tv recap is brought to
you by coors
pure do you ever feel like having a
balanced lifestyle is hard like you try
so hard to keep up with what is
considered balance
you push yourself every day getting
better and better but it can be
overwhelming
well enter course pure organic but chill
about it
the new coarse pure is a refreshingly
simple beer with organic barley
organic hops and water at 92 calories
and zero sugar it is the perfect beer to
celebrate the winds of everyday life
coarse pure is the perfect beer to
celebrate the winds of everyday life so
when you want to enjoy a beer
without the guilt reach for coors pure
it's organic but chill about it
go to coorspure.com toast to see where
you can find
course pure that's of course pure.com
toast
coors brewing company albany georgia are
you making fun of the way i was saying
course pure
no i wouldn't do that to you okay real
housewives of new york
so let's just like it's so pathetic okay
there were two things happening one was
this birthday party that was like
literally full of five people
um and then the song and i have to say i
did
get a serotonin moose like the whole i'm
depressed watching
real housewives of new york it's so
depressing but watching them all to sing
was actually a great joy and i have to
say who did you think was the best leah
oh i thought ramona was actually like
pretty good ramona was horrible
no okay well she didn't have pitch she
had like ruach
yeah no but her voice was i think the
worst even though they all have really
bad voices i thought that lia's was the
most pleasant but it's really crazy how
they each like none of them could carry
a two no it's crazy but i'm
so but wasn't this last christmas right
where's the song
maybe she's holding out for next or
maybe we'll find out why but she didn't
end up releasing the song no i've never
heard that song
there's no music video no yeah but what
are your thoughts on the whole like
legal thing like i kind of to agree with
leah like
it's weird that there's no release or
anything um but like everything luanne
does is janky like
right right it's not that she's like
being uh
shady shady she's just being janky and
i do agree with leah like you know you
gotta protect your bases
but what would like she's not getting a
release form from luanne so either do
the song or don't do the song yeah and i
didn't really understand
her logic because she wants to protect
herself
from what like what liability is there
singing on a song
um okay so she said like if the song say
it was using a sample of another song
and they like oh you know money on that
or say when this happens with songs that
you know it turns out it sounds too much
like another song and then you could be
sued
is everybody on the song liable in that
case like
yeah it's not the worst question no no
it's not and i actually thought it was
like a pretty reasonable request like
can we just sign a release is there like
a contract or anything but something
about the way leah goes about everything
just bothers me like yeah but it's not
even what she's doing
gets like so defensive she goes from
zero to 100 and she just starts like
not even answering the questions and
just starts like slinging insults
that it's not a conversation when she
becomes like so she veers the
conversation like
you don't think i'm trustworthy that's
not what we said no and also i did think
leah made a good point like this time
could come out and you know
a few it could go viral on tick tock and
literally become a huge song in five
years
do does fortune still get in perpetuity
like when does the donation end
right no these were all fair questions
and that's why i was struggling because
like if somebody else had asked it i
would be like yeah like what the [ __ ]
i finally is so irritating like i can't
stand by her for any for [ __ ]
yeah i can't i agree um
then there was this party which was so
bizarre and so weird and honestly when
leah was like i want to be in charge of
the cakes
i had no idea what she was doing and i
actually really was proud of ramona for
not like giving leo reaction
because that's exactly what leah was
trying to do leah is so like trying to
set ramona up to like
look bad she's obsessed with ramona and
likes
calling her out and like exposing her
and um and if
ramona had reacted i would have thought
she had every right too like it's
ramona's party and she's made it very
clear for whatever reason
she doesn't want to talk about dicks and
then she gets a big dick cake like it's
so stupid
i was so proud of ramona for not giving
her the slightest reaction i know but i
feel like ramona
it doesn't she's not even like mature
enough to be like i'm not going to give
her a reaction i feel like
her sometimes she has a reaction and
sometimes she doesn't and there's
i don't understand the method of like
the reason the rhyme or reason to what
offends her and what doesn't because she
is
very you know like sultry and like yeah
she likes to talk about like
men it's just that man sometimes but
then
sometimes the way leah says it it really
offends her so i don't understand like
what her ethos
is no me neither like it's okay because
i don't think that dick cake offended
her i didn't i don't think she was
trying to be cool about it i think she
was just cool with it
i don't know but i just finally got
annoying like she's just like doing
everything she can to like
give ramona ramona just looks bad when
ramona reacts
so she's just trying to get a reaction
out of ramona yeah i feel like she's
very sneaky leah like i really am like
hating her no she really is so obsessed
with trying to take down ramona both
covertly and overtly that it's ruining
her
own development on the show because
people like ramona remo like i feel like
ramona's actually having a really good
season where like
she's so integral to the group like she
really is
she's one of the few that like you know
wants a party and drink and it's like
down to do all of these things
and leah just doesn't get that she
doesn't get why people like ramona so
much
yeah totally and also i do think in
general ramona's reactions are
you you question them you're like is
this genuine is this not but then
when we were watching in last week's
episode the
seance and when her brother was brought
up and the way that she reacted which
was obviously so genuine this is
something that
deeply plagues her but her similar
her reaction you know physically and
just like the things she was saying was
like was a lot and it was it but it's
very much how she reacts
to women other things it just she's just
unlike other people she's not like other
girls remember she's not like other
housewives she you know so like
i just felt like that was actually a
really interesting window into like her
actual
soul and how she feels and how she
reacts in a genuine way and i'm like oh
then all those other times we're also
genuine
they just look strange totally um i did
think it was like incredibly bizarre for
ebony to invite all the women to black
shabbat which i want to talk about
in front of bershon when brishon was
invited like why not just send a text
um yeah well she obviously like started
she thought she was a little number sean
came she shouldn't have continued what
she was saying she should have switched
switched the shots yeah it was so
painful but also why can't bershon come
well because ebony said that all the
women
most of the people at the shabbat are
black and they're the black people she's
been to israel with and i guess that
doesn't include we're sean like why
can't we strong come
but i guess like coveted too i guess
it's another person already she was
using covet as like they're already in
the same pod
i don't think ebony likes bershon i like
bershon a lot me too
and i loved how i mean i watched last
week's and this week together i loved
how she just owned
that she was a little out of line in
what she said she said i acted familiar
and we are not familiar and i was like
that's exactly that's a perfect way to
phrase it yeah um
sonia like i'm really struggling with
her because i feel like the advice that
ebony is like empowering her with is
good but it's also like making her into
like a monster yeah
shown is becoming like a dictator like
yeah i just feel like ebony
and leah they don't like understand
they don't understand sonia it's just
like how bershon came in in the first
day they were like you know sony's like
this open book and you really feel
connected to her and then you also
realize she's a broken record yeah and
it's they think that
they don't understand the depth of the
issue and i actually feel like in their
own weird way ramona and luanne do
and they try to even though they put her
down and they speak to her and sometimes
ways that she should not be spoken to
i'm sure it's frustrating being friends
with sonia of course no
and like all this empowerment leah and
ebony are giving sonia are is going to
bite them in the ass because she's not
doing well
no she's not doing well and it's
technically good advice you know you
should like
don't let anyone walk all over you but
she's not applying it
in the normal right way right um cannot
wait for black shabbat
yeah i'm really so interesting though i
just watched your previews and it wasn't
then
so we're talking about and then it's not
even next week no
what the hell else could there be
there's literally nothing going on i
forgot what the previews had but it
wasn't
black shabbat okay well i was really
looking forward to that um
stay looking forward yeah i guess it was
just like fine it's such a bad show
like yeah it's not good it's not good i
do hope where shawn becomes full-time
because i also feel like right now the
women are writing her off like oh this
woman won't be around crazy lady who but
i do think people like her
love and i think she adds a lot to the
show and to see her home
and her like want to know about her
british banking ex-husband right and
every time we find out some information
about her personal life or her past like
it's so fascinating
yes i mean even just her story of being
13 years free from cancer like
interesting yeah let's talk about it
learn more so it's just like meh
and it's yeah and that's all i watch
because i was just like so engrossed in
the olympics but i did catch a couple
minutes of
tyler c and watched weapons live with
luen de los eps and he looked great
he did great i'm so proud of him i feel
like in an unofficial
capacity like i really trained him for
that moment yeah he didn't even know who
luanne was before he met me
no i watched a few minutes it was it was
a pleasure to watch and his girlfriend
was there
his girlfriend was there and matt was
there and tyler called both of them his
soul mates
oh cause um andy was like do you believe
in soul mates and he's like yeah i got
two right there oh my that's so sweet
i'm sure his girlfriend was like what
the [ __ ]
no stop no it's nice yeah sure but now
they have to like get married
um well it's been a pleasure sitting
here with you you as well um
always is apparently and that's it
that is it thank you guys would you like
to wrap up
no you can i'll be thinking of an emoji
okay yeah please
for my next instagram caption because
i'm always posting premium content at
jackie australia
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast monday morning show
where we deliver the five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anymore podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box
all the places so every listen to
podcast find us morning show sleep if i
start review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing day
truly truly okay you guys um the emoji
is the fist emoji and commemoration of
arthur
and it's last season yeah this is fist
for arthur have a great day you guys
love you
love you
you